tout est né d'une malle une drôle de mal
d'où sortent des musiques des couleurs
violettes léonard et louis sont trois
cousins ils se retrouvent dans le
grenier de leur enfance leur grande mère
a été envoûté et le sorcier chargé de
rompre son sortie neige leur demande de
retrouver des souvenirs musicaux
un compte où l'on voyage beaucoup l'idée
en fait c'est que la fameuse mme aminata
et et exploratrice et donc à rapporter
des instruments du monde entier qui sont
dans son grenier et du coup on va se
balader finalement partout dans le monde
avec toute cette collection
d'instruments et ans jouait pour les
faire découvrir au passage
pour les faire découvrir trois artistes
tous deux formations musicales
rosine et harpiste et pianiste benoît
percussionniste et thibaut
contrebassiste des formes et tous les
trois au conservatoire de versailles
ça a été l'endroit de notre première
rencontre mais au fur à mesure des
discussions s'est découvert cette
passion commune pour les autres le point
point de départ de tout ça c'est
peut-être notre curiosité commune
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a fondé
cette association a dit mme qui veut
dire l'association découverte et
d'initiation aux musiques du monde et en
fait c'est plutôt nous qui sommes
curieux au départ dont de tout faire de
toutes ces musiques de tous et culture
pour faire vivre ce conte musical depuis
15 ans le trio collectionne des
instruments de musique du monde entier à
la verrière et jouent leur spectacle ce
mercredi au scarabée et ils seront de
retour début décembre